half of the martial artist so it took me
a long time to kind of understand why I
started really training martial arts I
train I start training martial arts to
grow up that's why I began training in
the martial arts and I didn't know that
at the time at least not consciously I
didn't understand that that growing up
was what I really wanted I knew that I
wanted it to be able to take care of
myself I knew I wanted to try and be the
best human being that I could possibly
be in order to take responsibility for
my actions and make good decisions and
these are the things that I knew I
wanted which now i would say so he's
growing up but i wouldn't have said that
you know the seeking maturity was what I
was up to but that's why I began setting
to martial art and you know I guys that
has lots of different things you know
how can I you know better defend myself
when I was younger you know how can I
better win fights you know and as I got
older you know other ideas start to come
in but really the truth is I wanted to
grow up that's what I wanted to do I
wanted to learn how to grow up and I
remember one of my first serious martial
arts instructors I outlined a really
simple path for me that I still believe
is it's really a nice way to look at
this journey which is the first stage of
a martial artist is the fighter the
second stage is the soldier the third
stage is the warrior and the fourth
stage is the poet and then I remember
after he told me that you know and I
always figuring out some way to kick
someones a hat that's what I always
wanted to do in the beginning as you
know how do I fight better how do I
fight better that's what I wanted and I
remember him telling me after he told me
that patio he said from the perspective
of the fighter the poet doesn't look
very interesting but from the
perspective of the warrior it's the main
goal right and I've really come to
appreciate that as times gone on in and
try to become more and more the poet as
I as I mentioned on right so what are
these four stages and why are they
important the fighter is the first stage
in the path of the martial artist the
fighters job is to fight is to realize
they don't like their position they
don't like where they're at and
change that position right you have the
feeling of I'm a piece of [\h__\h] I'm not
good enough I can't get to the things I
want to get to and I want to change that
right I want to be better than I am and
that's what the fighter does fighter
tries to change their position they're
willing to have the courage to go forth
and take risks and get done what they
need to get done to become better as you
become a better a better fighter you
need to seek out an instructor right in
Japanese mythology to sensei this
someone who came before you who knows
the things that you don't know and then
as you find the sense that you find some
of you think has got some things under
control that you don't yet and that you
need to learn from you become the
soldier and the soldiers job is to
listen to the sensei right the sensei
will tell them all kinds of things think
they don't hear about themselves and
they have to be able to follow what the
sensei says in order to understand that
viewpoint and so once you get a sense a
your job is just to listen to the sensei
even if you think the sensei's wrongs
the sensei is going to know a lot of
things you don't you've already admitted
that this guy know stuff about the world
that I don't so you need to listen to
the sensei after you follow the path of
the soldier for a while your true path
will start to become clear and that's
when it's okay to leave the sensei and
if you have a good sense a they will
completely understand that it's time for
you to leave them right the path of the
Warriors when you walk your own path
completely you understand what you're
undertaking and on your own you're
trying to stay in the place you want to
be in and in rich your life without
having someone tell you what those
things are the warrior is you know
classically representing someone who is
in war there in a situation where
nothing cares about them everything
wants to see them destroyed and in the
face of that they're still able to stay
true and do the things they want to do
also you know there's the woodsman
allocated the woodsman which is the same
thing the woodsman lives out in nature
where nature doesn't care if he falls
off a mountain and cracks his neck you
know there's no one there to help him so
he's got to help himself so
self-reliance self control and the
ability to continue
go forth and do the things you want and
if you you know if you get two paths
where you can't understand what's going
on but you still have the skills of the
soldier you can listen to others and
take what they're saying very seriously
and actually listen to it as opposed to
just doing whatever you want right and
then as as you get better and better on
the path of the warrior you begin to see
the path of the poet right and the poet
is a guy who's able to reflect openly
and honestly about the world all the
beauty all the tragedy that the poet's
able to look at that and reflect that
back and so other people when they see
the poet they see themselves and the
truth of themselves being reflected back
the poet generally makes the best sense
a right the best instructor because
they're not putting their own crap on
you they're simply able to reflect back
what you're giving them and help you see
what you are so those are the four
stages of the martial artist and they've
been kind of pivotal in my life and
helping me figure out where I met and
what I need to do and see see the true
path that I'm actually on so I hope this
is useful to some people and sub half
I've been on the path of the martial
artists i'm chris hein this is like you
know fresno thank you for watching
you